[inaudible].
This short series will cover the grammar of sentences,
the very basics of syntax.
It will build on the introduction to morphology where we looked at words and
pieces of words.
This time we're moving from the form of words to the arrangement of words.
I'll use the terms grammar and grammatical in these lessons,
but they're different than how you may have heard them used in the past.
In linguistics,
the clearest point of comparison for what is grammatical would be this speech of
a native speaker of a language,
not a set of judgments from a Gra Marian or a teacher
that touches on a longstanding debate in linguistics.
Depending on your perspective,
you might check if a sentence is grammatical by asking a native speaker to judge
the sentence or you might check against other examples produced in that
language. Instead,
a simple way to conceive of grammar at this point is to treat it as a set of
rules which allows you either to accurately describe or produce sentences in a
specific language.
The first topic we'll look at is a clause.
A clause is in some ways a kernel sentence. It usually has a finite verb,
which means that the verb reflects something about the subject,
the dewar of the action. It usually has tents or aspect,
some way of indicating when or how the action takes place.
Clauses don't have to have a finite verb,
a small clauses often based around an infinitive,
an example of a small clauses to go to the store and that small clause might be
embedded into another clause we'll talk about embedding later,
but one example is I want to go to the store,
so want is the finite verb in the main clause in the main clause can be I want
it or in this case I want to go to the store and that's the main clause or the
matrix clause or the independent clause because you will find it on it's own a
dependent clause. We'll often have some introductory word like that or if,
and this allows you to identify the clause as needing to be put within another
clause in order to form a complete sentence.
This has been a very simple introduction to dependent clauses and independent
clauses,
but keep these in mind as we start to build more sentences in the next lesson.
[inaudible].